you
okay let me flip this board flip let's
go team black alrighty
mate and X pick that magic number 33 and
I am playing as black going for the
Sicilian I'm rooting for the team up top
here okay the grand prix attack let's go
with this and I think I want to
immediately get this strike in let's see
how my opponent responds if he 5 then I
have the f5 Square
if capture I capture with the pun I like
having that pandu oh I'm right I'm
trying to influence that particular
structure right away so now I think
without the epon around life becomes
difficult for this bishop let's develop
that night it's really weird only the
second time I'm doing this put pressure
on D for my opponent is having any of
that and
hmm okay let's get another night out a
hair after Castle I have to be really
concerned about a white rook getting to
of course white rook rook getting to e1
now what's nice is that sometimes after
this move is played this is when white
will capture on c5 but now what's nice
is that I'm able to recapture with Czech
and then I'll have time to Castle before
the rook could be of any bother to me on
the e-file now with this move there's
more pressure on the knight on c3 if I
were black and I am here I have to I
have to be defending on c6 here so do I
do that
by playing here I think I do actually
it's useful to do more than one thing
more than one aggressive thing with the
Queen and attacking the bishop and
defending here I would be strictly
defensive and I'm pretty sure I take
with the pawn I like reinforcing my
Center I also like giving this bishop a
new possibility so with that exchange I
have the light-square bishop s-- or i
have the bishop pair i should say i have
that x-factor bishop in that of the
white square guy and this is a very weak
point with these two pawns split like
this that could be problematic here so I
jump in right away to do I castle we're
about even on time do I keep the tension
or do I resolve it I wonder if I could
capture and after the recapture I play
here and you know what I think I might
be liking that because I would be
clearing the way for my Bishop to get on
the longest diagonal on the board now
I'll really try to show that this guy is
a tough guy
that he really has an influence on the
position so I'm considering this
followed by push I actually do have I
could be taking this pun let me see here
pawn takes pawn takes if Queen takes
pawn push here Queen here check is
annoying I'm gonna abandon that idea and
just go forward with castling if the
knight place to c3 I'll have to be
concerned about Knight a for Ponte now
now I'm ready to do this let's if white
makes a neutral move like Age 3 or
moving the King or something I'll take
and then push here and then push here
grabbing some space and opening again
this diagonal for him to be placed like
that so now I definitely want to open
the position up I have the bishop hair
that's one reason to open the position
up and I'm seeing that I have a lead in
development as well so let me do this am
I missing anything I don't believe so
and if he's playing here I could play
here with tempo if he's playing the f2 I
could play here with the tempo but that
comes not without dropping this pawn
which is maybe something I could afford
because I would be grabbing I would be
gaining some time for my Bishop to get
on this diagonal but now I could not
could do this advance so let me do that
I do have some concern about a knight
jumping into this square if I am going
to be playing on the main diagonal to be
concerned about ninety seven stuff my
knight is there to defend but this seems
like it's too good of a diagonal to not
go there and now I want my Queen here
now the King is on the same diagonal
which means this pawn is pinned if I
wanted to throw a piece here I could
maybe that'll come about at some point
maybe seems very crazy but maybe there's
some ideas with Queen here too
here jump my knight in here looks really
weird that's that's well two reasons
maybe I could just go here I have h3
available
like if pawn push like I'm already seen
I'm not well this is this would just be
a bad move right the pawn is pinned he's
powerless from capturing in this
direction so I could go here is there
anything that it could be tacking along
is third-ranked I do that 126 about a
minute disadvantage I just need some
more pieces working
okay let's try this I'm assuming the
night's gonna drop back or some pieces
gonna have to defend and then I'll drop
back I want to I want to get my rook
here soon I'm not sure which one
although I'm gonna go with this one
maybe there's some tricky stuff against
f7 I want to keep this rook around to
defend when I play rook here in Bishop
here less than a minute if if we're into
Blitz mode I'm gonna be trying to move
the white pieces maybe try to make a
rook a white rook move or something okay
that's defended they're still in a pin
let's get my rook opposite the Queen now
they're out of the pin let's drop back
is that safe better be safe Queen here
Bishop here next I'd like to get an f6
to really take over this square this is
the this is the glue for the white
position 45 seconds
okay now I can't even go there
okay let's do that I want to throw my
knight in to g4 he's my queen in draft
now g3 queen here she is way short on
squared so no Knight here I could take
the knight if if I need to
oh my Queens dead oh no my Queens dead
look those backward moves those backward
moves I'm gonna try to still be sneaky
somehow can I get made on h2o
no my queen was way short on squares h5
self self something self self trap I
travel by a lead okay could I jump in
here can I jump in here oh man I have a
nice post for my knight but that's far
compensation it's not a queen jump in
here less than 30 Oh No
let's secure my knight Bishop here I
guess mmm-hmm defense need a lot of
defense he's ready to go here and just
trap my rook oh he could he could be um
oh that's a no this is some trouble
isn't it there's Knight stuff here is
this safe
get my rook over here age - I'm looking
for right now each - h1 well I'll go
fast or something give a check on each
one Knight takes pawn my bishops hanging
like a tongue it even Queen oh I'm dead
here oh no that's me Oh game Oh deadly
let's go back that was so crazy let's
put that board ah try it my queen let me
actually look from my perspective for
real this time
ah man I like my position so much until
I played age five okay what can I offer
right here I think after this d5
movement you don't have the epon around
I think it's a problem the bigger
problem is my age five minutes but
getting back to this structure right
here I don't think you could capture
here and have that be good I think so
what are your options to play e5 it does
give me these square and not these
squares but the f5 square right yeah I
think without the epon around black is
already quite close to equal and maybe
even starts to be better because like I
was pointing out the Dark Star Bishop
has some trouble so how else did it go
down here yeah I think that's maybe
going to be the main suggestion I have
with regard to the pawn structure right
no yeah cuz this I turn out to have that
advantage of the bishop pair the
position is opening up so that those
those things can't be bad
how could I have done better I have to
come up with a better plan I was maybe
maybe my knight belongs here he does
doesn't he yeah he belongs here I never
got him there she was she was going in a
direction she shouldn't have really gone
in that was I guess too easy to be
defending against g2 I thought I could
always drop back here yeah it's I tried
my own cool oh that stinks okay so you
just get out of the pin Age 5 that's
beautiful isn't it let's watch that
again looks from the black side here man
okay so yeah I think if if if I could
have it if I could do it over again I
would really give I don't think that
this is a bad move shifting my queen
over here this is maybe unnecessary I
think my focus should have been to
eliminate this night and I could do so
by playing f6 so that involves first
posting my knight here temporarily
obstructing my bishop from seeing these
squares directly but I think this
followed by f6 would be an improvement
on the black side but this is let's just
watch this train wreck one more time
there really wasn't no way out right no
I was saying it too I was like my queen
is way short on squares so apparently I
wanted to eliminate even more let's take
away two let's take away the only to
save squares my Queen had in pledge five
oh that is painful H Bishop II one who
sees those moves those backward moves
man dadly I still felt like I coulda won
with this tricky night he's a really
it's a good post
if material was even this is a good pose
for the night but we're beyond repair
here I mean there are even some tactical
no I thought there's a tactical shot
against my bishop it's like Knight takes
hear about my night is there to defend
uh what a train wreck
clean snuck in here you did like a queen
little dance ah f7 that's a matin too
I'm a good game nice
you